عجله الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تتوقف عن
الدوران فصول اربعه عاشتها المعركه في
انتظار فصل خامس
تستعد لصد هجوم روسي المحتمل خلال الربيع
هجوم يسبقه تكتيك روسي جديد يتمثل في
اطلاق مناطيد تحمل عاكسات رادار فوق
اوكرانيا للحصول على معلومات بشان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لاجبار كياف على
استنزاف مخزوناتها القيمه من الذخيره
وصواريخ ارض جو حسب الدفاع البريطانيه
لمواجهه ذلك الاوكرانيون فتحوا خطه تعبئه
طوعيه جديده وفق صحيفه الطاعنت الصحيفه
ذاتها نقلت عن مستشار زيليسكي قوله ان
معركه السيطره على باخموت مهمه وان
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عنها ابدا اذ تعتبرها
مفتاح الصراع ولا مجال لخسارتها فالسيطره
على باخموت ستشكل نقطه انطلاق بالنسبه
لروسيا للزحف نحو مدينتين اكبر هما اكرم
تورس كواسلوفياسك اللتين تقعان ابعد
باتجاه الغرب في دونيتسك ما سيعيد الزخم
قبل الذكرى الاولى لانطلاق الحرب ولتحقيق
هذا الهدف تطالب اوكرانيا حلفائها
الغربيين بالمزيد من الطائرات المقاتله
والدبابات الحربيه المتقدمه في وقت تؤكد
انها تحتاج ايضا صواريخ بعيده المدى لصد
الهجوم الروسي واستعاده السيطره على
المناطق التي خسرتها فالجيش الاوكراني
يستهلك القذائف بوتيره اسرع مما يمكن
للغرب ان يصنع حسب رويترز ما يمثل عقبه
اخرى امام قوتكياف خلال المرحله المقبله
بلال البجديني العربيه